faced uh lavon on the other hand he's a
little bit more dynamic these days he
likes to complicate and both these
players
one is very confident the other one has
quiet confidence ah should we predict an
entertaining game when these two are up
against each other david definitely i
can't see this one being boring jeffrey
won't want to shut this game down he
won't want to just you know make it very
quiet and go for a drawing wow we do see
the retti opening so white doesn't even
occupy the center with the pawn yet
we do see maybe a transposition
potentially to a queen's gambit and
okay it's actually a kind of reversed
queen's gambit uh levon aronian is the
one offering the gambit this time so
offering white the chance to capture a
pawn this last move is very rare as far
as i know
uh
it has forced jeffrey to start thinking
at an early stage and look at this it's
a mutual gambit there both sides
offering up pawns in the center and
level on aronian
he has chosen this rare line is he well
prepared that is the big question for me
jeffrey as ivanka mentioned he likes to
have a really smooth transition from the
opening to the middle game he normally
wants to pick up an advantage just kind
of
grind that advantage out uh transform it
late maybe later on here he's already
forced to think on just move four yeah
he has a choice you know is he going to
support the pawn that's under attack is
he going to push that
d pawn one square forward he can also
play even more aggressively and actually
pick up the pawn in front of the king
and move it two squares i mean so much
choice and i guess he's gonna take the
decision actually it was a very
stylistic decision right now already on
move four first critical moment of the
game yeah and maybe we can jump in you
mentioned a few moves there your anchor
so in the current position white has
just given up a pawn on this square
what should he play and you mentioned
three four moves there yeah i'm yeah so
number one top choice is actually a
solid choice just to pick up the pawn in
front of the king move it one square and
he hasn't he's gone for a different
option he's instead pushed that pawn
forward which is a little bit more
maximalistic because this white is
saying hey you're going to take the
space i can and that is why levon oroni
is like no no i'm not going to let that
porn live that easy life and instead
challenges it yep so challenging this
pawn in the center and
again decision time for jeffrey he needs
to defend this pawn
in some way he develops his knight to
defend it and now after a capture will
he trade the queens that's the big
question
do you take this pawn back with your
queen do you take it back with the
knight
well
the computer says you take it back with
a queen and you go into an
and it's off the board potentially by
move six wow i mean that doesn't mean
it's gonna be boring but it does mean
that we will go into a very different
type of position
one where maybe levon aronian will be
frustrated that he won't have too many
dynamic chances that's what he wants
then again it's all about concrete uh
concrete factors right now can jeffrey
win his pawn back black still has this
one extra pawn and if he can win it back
will he have an advantage i like white's
pieces though look at these nights
really really strong in the centre of
the board this one threatening to jump
in that will be a night fork
winning material and i was
yeah
i got a bit excited there because i
suddenly had a glitch
well i thought lavonna played a new move
but he hadn't it was totally mainstream
um okay this was the big threat uh if
black for example had ignored it then
this is a night fork devastating winning
the rook in the corner so uh levon
played not a new move developing his
bishop
to cover this square
yeah and uh i'm expecting now jeffrey to
play the most natural move in the
position push your king's pawn forward
try to win this pawn back maybe try and
push this pawn forward to destabilize
kick away the black bishop
lots of choice yep that would be the uh
maximalist approach actually to push the
pawn forward there is one other tiny
move that
jeffrey can play it's a bit more subtle
but it's just gaming
aiming to recapture the pawn and that's
just to retreat the knight to the square
that david highlighted
and then planning to play knight takes
pawn
yep going for the pawn and maybe the
bishop afterwards
wow i actually really like it for white
i'm surprised the level of nerolian has
gone into this willingly
he's played instantly every move levon
he's up to 15 and
15 minutes 40 seconds he's gained a lot
of time on the clock already jeffrey
thinking
but it looks great for white how do you
stop this plan knight takes porn i mean
even if the white knight is attacked in
the centre of the board you can just
ignore that just playing knight takes
pawn give away your knight in the center
but you counter attack against the black
bishop and suddenly it's knights versus
bishops in the center but white knights
are
doing really really well
i think this gives an advantage to white
it looks very strange to me i mean we
don't see this often do we on the
analysis board we do see both knights
and two black bishops yeah in the center
hardly any pawns very rare yeah i mean
it's completely just knights against uh
bishops right now
and
i think the knights are winning um also
it's so rare to see after just eight
moves only the queens have been traded
off normally knights disappear first or
bishops
this time it's the queens
i've absolutely now i i'm also
appreciative of the pattern there kya
it is a very unusual situation that the
knights are doing damages against the
bishops because we often say a pair of
knights are not that great but in that
particular situation it was good and uh
now the decision is in geoffrey's hands
you know he's going to try to expand in
the center
move the knight it's a pleasant choice i
mean i have to say taking a look at the
statistics it's not a popular opening
choice by lavon i mean he has to have
some new idea
cooked up somewhere because the last
time a top grandmaster played this
opening was in 2007
ha
really
yes yes yes
that long ago and it was uh grishak
against ivan chuk
and jeffrey chong at that time how old
was he well let's not
[Laughter]
the question is has he seen that game
maybe not
well the question is what what does a
aronian bringing to the table because
okay
he's developed his knight
he's bringing to the table a bunch of
bishop retreats as well black's bishop
now has gone to the b8 square it's not a
great square but it does keep control
over the white knights the white knights
can't jump further forward that's the
key right now and
i mean this opening the reason it's so
rare is it does have a dodgy reputation
but sometimes with the help of computers
we've uh we've discovered that actually
old openings long forgotten openings
like this one which hasn't been played
for 15 years at the top level
sometimes they are viable the computer
might say oh it's only a tiny advantage
for white anyway so top ground masters
they say okay it's fine i'll survive
even if it's just plus seven uh plus
point seven for white it's not the
biggest deal in the world and aronian he
thinks he's okay and he definitely is
having jeffrey think here and uh
in sort of the honor of
bobby fischer who was not all that big
of a fan of openings he invented 960
chess to get just out of opening prep uh
is that a little bit of levon's plan
here to surprise jeffrey with something
he's just
to get him into time trouble basically
yeah definitely definitely um talking
about uh delving into the past and
finding little explored ideas this was
actually bobby fisher's speciality you
know he he didn't have a team behind him
he just loved to look at uh chess books
the old history books and just think
about those ideas you know he
revitalized so many openings because
he'd of his approach and he was a real
maverick and maybe
maybe i'm sure level knows that it's
50th
yeah yeah yeah and this is perhaps
no maybe it's too much it might be some
little tribute well maybe we will see
the players today sort of take it out of
opening prep in the games in honor of
bobby fischer that would be very cool
yeah it's definitely a trend anyway i
think to take things out of opening
preparation maybe we'll see some cool
games one with white's light square
bishop that was bobby fisher's favorite
piece
maybe we'll see more night offs today
bobby fisher's uh favorite opening is
black maybe we'll see one b3 which
occasionally bobby fischer experimented
with really lots of lots of options but
in general he always said one e4 best by
tess so that's what players should be
playing with white none of jeffrey's one
knight f3 stuff
well e4 came there e4 came there exactly
that was good timing david
i'll pretend i planned that
moved on better late than never and
white now occupies the center white
tonight's still looking great to be
honest yep absolutely and it's now down
to levon to try and neutralize those
white knights maybe try to change uh
exchange off one of them
over the next couple of moves
yes absolutely and uh what i really like
about bobby fischer's eve best buy test
quote is that yeah he always opened up
with his kingsporn
but
the most important game of the match in
game six he opened up with a queen sport
was it no it wasn't the queen's point it
was transposed
to a variation that you would find in
the queen's pawn aha and there he won
such a superb game this was the game i
was referring to that but boris baskey
actually just
after they finished just applauded him
yeah i was just incredible everyone was
just like did you see the way bobby
played
and uh wow i guess which game of the
match that was
game games day six always game six yeah
and we're gonna dig deeper into that
game tomorrow actually david in iceland
and a replica of the board they played
on is gonna take us in detail through
that game but today later in today's
show david's uh in iceland gonna take us
through game one with uh i think you you
said the biggest blunder in world chess
championship history yeah that's right
um it's commonly known now as uh kind of
what not to do in an endgame what not to
do with your bishops don't go and grab
any poison pawns but uh there's a lot to
learn from that one moment and
someone as great as bobby fisher could
make that kind of blunder than anyone
can so a lot to learn from that one game
and i think that's what maybe added to
the drama game one of the match bobby
blundered horribly and lost so
what a start to that yeah historic
layman that's coming after game two
today straight after game two we're
gonna dig into game one in the 72 match
yeah and uh this one is actually heating
up despite the fact that queens are off
the board both sides now they've castled
on opposite flanks black has gone one
way white has gone the other way
and maybe that will open up one of the
kings to attack white's king does look a
bit airy doesn't have too many uh
pawns around it to protect so we will
see is white's king safe on this flank
opposite side castling in a middle game
with queens would be really really
dramatic here
maybe slightly less so but still
ambitious from jeffrey john and it still
looks you know a little strange with the
kings on opposite sides i feel we need a
like a rhyme for this we have rhymes for
so many things
i want to rhyme for opposite side
castling
because it's always dramatic
well we're going to have to ask everyone
on twitter these are our geniuses that
we constantly refer to i mean do you
guys can you can you think of a rhyme
to do with opposite castling tweet us
using the hashtag chesschamps and uh we
will feature them we will definitely
mention our show
and uh okay we do have a move um lebron
has moved his rook to just enhance the
support on the e7 knight
yeah i think black's one big problem
here and the reason the evaluation bar
is so far in white's favor is because
for example if white just improves his
worst-paced piece say this rook i mean
maybe there are better moves might have
moved but say he swings it to the center
then how is black ever going to deal
with this bishop the problem is this
bishop
has no safe squares there's nowhere it
can really jump to the one move you
don't want to play is bishop takes pawn
here on h2 this would be very very
similar to something we'll see a bit
later on this is very similar to the
blunder that fisher made in game one of
the match exactly 50 years ago taking a
pawn but after the pawn steps forward
the g pawn then this black bishop is
trapped it's in no man's land white will
simply go and pick it up later with his
rook this is actually the exact same
blunder that fischer made different
position but the same theme so uh the
one thing uh level iranian shouldn't do
is go and grab a pawn with his bishop
but if he can't do that then his bishop
is stuck and therefore the rook in the
corner is also stuck and that that is
where levon aronian's problems lie in
those two pieces he's never going to be
able to develop them in the near future
at least so uh jeffrey if i were him i
would just look for an improving move
okay he doesn't want to just maintain
the tension i'm not such a fan of this
knight exchange because after
i mean you could take back with a black
knight but for example if you take that
with a black rook this is a bit scary it
looks like you've abandoned the back
rank but at the moment the black knight
defends this square so the white rook
cannot zoom up to the top of the board
to give a check but uh the reason i'm
not such a big fan for white is that now
this bishop does have a safe square it
can move on the next go
not a great square maybe but at least it
gets off the back rank and once this
bishop moves black could start
untangling his pieces yeah you've been
praising those nights david why would
jeffrey um
get it off the board yeah it's the
modern school of chess car
younger players they're very very direct
i've noticed younger players they don't
want to keep the tension too much and
here look at what jeffrey's doing he's
actually sacrificing a pawn
he's hoping this pawn is captured but in
order to uh free up this light square
bishop he has had to push this pawn
forward now the idea is to swing this
bishop across and onto this diagonal i
talked about this rook in the corner
being the problem piece and actually
it's a big big target right now so
i think that's where the generations
differ
an older well slightly older player like
me uh in the previous position i would
just be thinking oh let's just improve a
piece get all my pieces into the battle
first and then look for action later
young players they're like no no no
action now and you have the problem to
solve how do you stop my bishop coming
to this diagonal
if you can solve it then great well done
if you can't i'm gonna win a quick game
so uh that's what jeffrey is thinking
this is a big threat to move his bishop
to this diagonal i think um levon here
has to just develop as quickly as
possible get these bishops into the game
he could start by maybe bringing his
bishop forward and meeting this bishop
move with uh another bishop move of his
own this still looks very scary to be
honest white's knight jumping in
attacking this bishop looks very very
scary for levon aronian
this is what jeffrey's planning yeah
definitely i mean this position that
you've got up on the analysis board i
would be terrified i mean there's so
much pressure and it's very concrete
play actually from j
from jeffrey you know he's saying you
know there's something fundamentally
wrong with this position that you have
i'm going to prove it directly and
it's
it's difficult isn't it
very difficult
i mean anything anything that black
plays there's going to be some
concession yeah i mean you would love to
at some point move your knight out the
way for example developing your bishop
and then maybe moving your knight but
the problem is you can never do this
this would end up in checkmate the
background checkmate so it's two
problems dual problems here um as you've
mentioned in the current position it's
not just the fact that the king is
potentially trapped but uh also this
diagonal very vulnerable so
i said it's the modern school of chess
going direct trying to pose immediate
problems to your opponent before they're
ready
but maybe it's just very good chess
maybe it's just very strong
um this direct threat
i'm struggling to see an immediate way
to parry this
um i mentioned developing black's
bishops okay he develops this one first
maybe his idea after the white bishop
moves
okay the white bishop didn't move um but
i was going to say maybe his idea is to
somehow protect his back rank
um instead if we go back jeffrey decides
okay he's going to solidify this pawn
chain solidify in the center and next
move this bishop is coming yeah
and black still has the problem of that
dark square bishop it's not a great
piece i mean it doesn't have any long
diagonals to look at and at the minute
it's just stuck there on the eighth row
so
levon will have to do some repair work
there and meanwhile white
very nice position you know a lot of
flexibility with the bishops that light
square bishop pointing to a fantastic
diagonal i'm also looking at the other
dark square bishop can also move
if it needs to
yeah this bishop can come around right
and start attacking this black rook yeah
and of course the knight can just hop in
i mean so many
good possibilities available to jeffrey
wow we're spotting a lot of ideas for
white
fewer ideas for black so that's the
situation right now let's go back to the
players jeffrey
he spent a bit more time than levon but
he has a very pleasant position and
levon he is spending his time now this
is what top players do right they
realize their position is difficult and
then they invest the time
and he does get his bishop finally off
the back rank
so that rook in the corner can breathe
it can breathe once more yep
and
very tense position here and uh well
it's an exciting day isn't it i mean it
was absolutely fascinating yesterday and
very thrilling to watch all those
youngsters win but of course you know we
really like it when everyone shares
shares with us where they're watching
the show from and uh we do have a selfie
from
hagon ii abhishek
who says oh
my computer another chess day of at
school and this is what gets him going
though at five
five years old he is still learning the
names of the chess pieces
so there's abhishek and his child
and it's not just abhishek sharing with
us a selfie akhil is also sharing saying
hopefully my boss doesn't watch the
stream too
well
well then the boss would also send a
selfie and then you know
even even stevens yeah that would be
good yeah yeah i mean chess is good for
the brain anyway exactly and you need a
lunch break anyway right exactly so why
don't you have like a 40 and five minute
break while the games are going on and
then you can work a little bit yeah yeah
and you know we did ask
for a rhyme yeah opposite side castling
i actually thought of one immediately
after i tweeted but okay daniel first of
all daniel dayro says opposite side
castling guarantees fighting and can be
exciting oh i like it yeah it's very
good i i my opposite side casting this
is my one guarantees singing and dancing
oh i like that one too
yeah yeah yeah
i don't normally come up with rhymes my
brain is a bit slow
you're always too good with that david
all always have something
david is still trying to work one out
it's taking me a little bit longer today
i will get one by the end of the show i
thought maybe is it easier if we say
like kings on opposite sides yeah kings
on opposite sides something rhyming with
his eyes
yeah we'll think of one yeah we'll think
of more
for sure
yeah it's my rhyming brain is not
clicked yet
i'm just too focused on the moves
well this definitely is a strange
strange game piece is just all over the
place what's going on yeah jeffrey is so
ambitious and uh look at jeffrey's face
as well so focused he's calculating
right now he's jumped in with his knight
he's attacking black's light squared
bishop and the question is for level
iranian do you have to exchange off one
of your bishops for this night
i think white's knight is just too
strong you can't let it live anymore you
just have to take it off the board and
maybe just to show you what's about to
happen over the next couple of moves uh
this night as mentioned it's attacking
this bishop
you cannot really run away anywhere safe
with this bishop so you just have to
trade off the knight white's rook will
recapture
and white's rook is very strong but at
least everything it's kind of attacking
right now it's defended
and uh i think level around maybe he can
consider trying to exchange off one set
of rooks i was wondering at first
whether he could play knight takes pawn
this was a big big question but uh i
think here after
a couple of exchanges it looks like a
skewer here attacking both bishops at
the same time but i think white can just
about survive by bringing his king
forward black's rooks double up hitting
the two bishops and now white moves one
of the bishops attacking this black rook
so this is what the players are
calculating it's like a three-four move
variation but black cannot sacrifice his
knight
uh profitably right now so
i'm assuming instead black would maybe
just try and trade off a set of rooks
maybe jump in with his knight to attack
some pawns
uh ideally
black needs something now because
long-term white has the bishop pair but
the game does go on black is relatively
solid for now at least over the next
couple of moves he could also consider
pushing this pawn forward trying to
break down the strong
point of white's pawn chain
so uh yeah lots of ideas for
levon nerolian the clock has basically
balanced itself up um or levon only has
a small time advantage now
but either way he is the one facing the
questions in the current position he
needs to eliminate this white knight and
then he needs to consider what to do
next
yeah and i have to say i'm a bit puzzled
as to why levon is thinking so much for
me it's a given you've got to remove
that night yeah it's too good and uh
yeah there he is in uh
with this thinking cap on and i love
again i love seeing how the players
just get up close and personal with
their computer you have uh lavon kind of
treating it almost like he's at
a physical board yeah meanwhile
meanwhile jeffrey just looks so chill
does he does i actually have never
played against jeffrey i've never seen
him in action does he
does he sit like this at the board
yes yes he does yeah i think i've played
him three times over the board and
the first time i won very quickly as
white he just looked nice and chilled
the whole time he had a dead lost
position but he just looked really happy
and i was like wait
i'm winning right and he was just like
calmly making moves the next time i
played him actually actually was one of
the most embarrassing moments of my
career because i arrived at the board i
sat down
i started writing on the scoresheet and
then the arbiter came up to me he's like
oh you're on the wrong side of the table
and i'd prepared uh with the black
pieces against a different opponent
it turns out i was white against jeffrey
because
in all play all tournaments if you play
the same opponent twice in a tournament
they actually switched the pairings at
some point so i hadn't checked who i was
playing i hadn't checked the colors i
just assumed i was playing the same guy
i played in the first half
and i turned out to be playing jeffrey
and i lost really quickly because i just
wasn't prepared oh no i prepared with
black all morning i ended up playing
with white and i was like how do the
pieces move again
so yeah the second time i played jeffrey
was a disaster i lost and then the next
time was a draw but um yeah he's very
calm uh he very rarely betrays emotion
ah and we've seen him in interviews he's
really
really nice guy really well spoken
really calm
he's really realistic as well about his
improvement he will do all the things
that are necessary in order to improve
um i've got another funny jeffrey story
once i was uh
i had to rebook a flight a long story
but uh i rebooked flight and i ended up
somehow it was really last minute i
ended up sitting on the seat next to him
some random flights in the middle of
nowhere out of all the flights all the
people in the world i ended up sitting
next to jeffrey really so uh yeah and
did you have a nice chat then on the
plane
yep uh that was just after i lost to him
uh yeah it was a nice uh nice chat and
yeah actually we were giving each other
kind of blindfold uh problems to deal
with like study study like end games
and
he knows a lot
he studies uh these types of things all
the time wow
well it's so much fun to get to to know
him a little bit better it's his first
time in the tour and he is playing some
impressive chess definitely yeah chance
is his life it's uh yeah it's well
deserved that he's here do is his
ambition to be uh you know top player in
the world the
world champion in the future
i think so i mean he was world junior
champion at 15 and that's under 20. so
years in advance he's 21 now but i think
he's finding it hard to maybe crack the
world's elite that's another level the
2750 plus
type of player like levon aronian but
this could be a start i mean uh it's
it's rare to get the opportunity to play
so many of these top dogs in one week uh
kind of in one go so
i mean it'll be a confidence boost for
him and of course as we talked about
before as well it it's been two years of
covent
which has been devastating especially
for the young players two years without
playing over the board
you know confidence has gone down for
many of them it's very exciting to
follow it's exciting to follow them now
as they get to play more again in
competitions yeah definitely and we're
seeing the kind of uh the reward for the
work they've done during covert during
lockdown and actually we didn't see the
move we expected javanco we saw a bit of
a flashy sequence there the knights have
left the board yeah i was
i was surprised by the order of it i had
seen this idea of jumping in with the
night but not not at this particular
time and now we have uh
well two rooks by four rooks and four
bishops on the board
and uh the only big difference
is
the porn majorities if you look you know
white is uh
said they've got two pawns on the left
and four pawns on the right and so it's
all going to be about uh which side can
first of all activate their pieces and
at the same time utilize their past
pawns
and it's like once again it looks like
jeffrey is making all the right moves
yeah look at this he's putting so much
pressure on black's position he just
gave a really nasty check and black's
king's been forced towards the center
and i think we have to jump in maybe we
can keep an eye on the players because
it's actually going to be a very
dramatic moment uh right now if we just
backtrack slightly this is the current
position if we backtrack to this moment
where i was advocating taking the white
knight off the board neville naronian
found a really flashy move he jumped in
with his knight counter-attacking
against the white bishop this knight was
removed and black removed the white
knight now so this is how the knights
left the board if white had taken this
bishop then black's rook suddenly gets
very very active and jeffrey did not
want to see this and i think he made a
wise decision
he retreated his bishop levon did the
same and uh now the problem for black
and this is uh gonna be a persisting
problem is that once his rook moves if
the rook had moved then suddenly white
jumps into the seventh rank and we call
this seventh heaven for a reason it's
because this is where all the targets
are the two bishops now lined up white's
also attacking this pawn uh very
important point especially when the
bishop jumps to the diagonal
and uh this would have been disastrous
instead levon had to block with the pawn
and after a check this is the current
position black's king did not want to go
to the corner just in case for example
after a porn exchange it will get
trapped in the corner uh in a variation
like this one
but uh
yeah it feels like even going towards
the center it's not going to find safety
there and
the first thing jeffrey should calculate
whether it's good or not is the simple
move pawn takes pawn
going for a capture trying to win a pawn
attacking a black rook at the same time
it looks nice and beautiful i guess you
have to wonder what happens after this
bishop now
gets freed up takes a pawn with a check
hitting the white king maybe the king
just moves and level around how is he
going to deal with the problem with his
rook
i don't really see it ivanka this looks
really um really terrible for black to
be honest after pawn takes pawn white
can just recapture with his bishop no
matter where the rook runs away to now i
mean say it goes here suddenly we see
why the black king is not safe
anymore suddenly the white rook lines up
and yes there's a couple of bishops in
the way but clear target
um yeah i mean i i hate lavon's position
actually i think he's losing and i think
the bar also agrees with us
this move i also quite like as well
loved your line also was instinctively
drawn to this one which is just saying
you know let's increase the tension
after all black can't really play pawn
takes pawn on account of the pin from
the bishop against the rook the rook
would just drop off um this is a really
nasty pin actually along this diagonal
and
yes a pawn was hanging levon says give
him give me that pawn but jeffrey says
okay i'm happily giving you that pawn
because now i'm going to sidestep no
matter where you drop back your bishop
now say you drop it back to a safe
square suddenly pawn takes pawn is going
to be deadly because look at this a pawn
recapture will end up in checkmate
queens are off the board but still
jeffrey zhong the youngster is attacking
and checkmating ideas on the board right
now
nephilian in big big trouble
it looks like the youngster might be
taking this game yeah totally i mean
the line that you showed is just
devastating
check me on the board and the worst
thing is
what else do you do what else to do i
mean there's only one move that i can
see here and that is actually to
centralize the bishop centralize it to
this question to this square just with
the hope that me ah okay i forgot the
golden rule look for counter attacks
country attacks i think here javanka
there would have been a really flashy
move bishop takes pawn as well would
have been really nasty because again
this checkmating idea on the board and
uh the one trap there we should mention
was pawn takes pawn would actually run
into white uh maybe getty checkmated
because of the power of these two
bishops so bishops are so tricky uh in
the end level nerone as you mentioned
did counter-attack this bishop was too
strong on this diagonal so he pushed a
pawn forward distracting it and after
bishop takes pawn
same problem for levon aronian where to
run away with this bishop
if he runs away back to the center then
maybe
okay he has done so maybe jeffrey's just
going to
he has just retreated his bishop and uh
put it back on the diagonal it came from
in the process he's won a pawn yeah
exactly i mean and you still reignite
the threat of bishop take spawn i mean
it's just
i mean look at the crisscross effect of
these bishops and they're all pointing
towards this black king and whoa level
neronian when in trouble he loves to
muddy the waters he's pushed a pawn
forward
i mean everything's hanging here for
example black isn't even threatening
anything if white just takes a quiet
timeout uh black is not threatening to
win this bishop because once again
checkmate the same pattern again the
king trapped
and uh
if white however gets greedy and doesn't
wait then suddenly after pawn takes pawn
white is the one in big big trouble
along these two diagonals suddenly the
white king is the one
perishing simply
so both kings now under heavy fire the
evaluation bar says plus 3.5 that means
a winning advantage but what is the
killer move
um i don't see it right now maybe it is
a waiting move i just want to get this
king to safety to stop this bishop
coming and giving a check
yeah i mean a waiting move appeals to me
also just bring the rook across i was
going to say introduce another
player into the party you know bring the
rook across i like that move a lot yeah
i mean for example you could bring the
rook across and suddenly white's rooks
are lining up against the black king if
the position opens up if black touches
this pawn this pawn or this bishop then
lines are just going to open up against
the black king looks like the black king
is in mortal danger right now
okay he just retreats his bishop jeffrey
he's going for a different angle going
for this angle towards the black king
beautiful i love it no i mean it's so
unexpected i was just looking in terms
of up and down i did not look behind
those backward moves for the bishop i
mean it's just it's brilliant it's
brilliant and it should be winning no
matter what black does now bishop takes
porn is a killer threat
wow jeffrey at 21 he beat anish geary
yesterday
and uh now he's going to beat levon and
only
well just it's going to be under 30
moves i don't see a way that level 1 can
actually survive this for much longer
too many threats if you defend this pawn
that's attacked by
by the white bishop for example by
moving your bishop to a passive square
then white just simply plays pawn takes
pawn says thank you very much i'm
attacking your rook when the rook moves
i'll take another pawn uh you could take
it with your rook as well but two pawns
uh it's gonna be an easy easy win here
for jeffrey and you can tell on levon's
body language he looks
devastated it's gonna be a win for white
this game
and uh wow crushing absolutely crushing
there's nothing to do yeah i mean
i don't see a move here simply well the
youngsters played fantastic yesterday
and they are keeping it going today it's
looking great for jeffrey hans niemann
the youngest american in the tournament
has gotten three points against lenia
dominguez
young christopher duda won his game
against wei and anish kiri not one of
the youngsters but he is younger than
team rajabov and giri starting the day
with three very important points the
nightmare continues for team rajabov
and well level naronian he did get some
points yesterday but it wasn't a good
day and it continues today looks like
about to lose against the 21 year old i
mean yesterday to be honest it looked
like he was a little bit jinxed you know
you know he mentioned it himself that
you know he had taken a pause from this
online chess
and uh well
things are not going his way right now
and just he's about to lose an exchange
at the very least yep white's bishop can
win one of the black rooks uh you can
take it now
and it looks very healthy looks like a
big material advantage for white
maybe he'll be looking for something
else here jeffrey maybe there are some
threats against the white king that he
has to be wary of
but uh either way if he's accurate here
then it should be winning
for example i was about to say he could
play pawn takes pawn this black rook
that is attacked now is actually pinned
it cannot move
and this is just gonna win a whole bunch
of material for white
evaluation bar says it it confirms what
we're thinking
black is going down
black at the very best is just gonna
survive with a bishop for a rook and
that's just uh terminal anyway yeah i
realized i just used the word exchange
that's where chesapeake there
just means a minor peaceful rook
yup
ling the exchange
yeah exchange sacrifices are a big theme
in chess as well but this is no
sacrifice this is losing the exchange
and that's not great
yeah so uh yeah bishop for rook
advantage will be decisive here for
jeffrey
and yeah poor levon he just
struggling to find his form but it's not
even the fact that levon's played badly
this game maybe it was just a poor
opening choice and he never recovered
but
jeffrey's just been inspired in this
game i can't fault any single move from
uh jeffrey at all i can barely follow
any single one move from level neroni
and it's no blunder in this game just
really smooth performance yeah i agree
with you it just seems to be
a bad opening from levon and i have to
say when this move first appeared in on
the on the games on the boards
i was like oh my goodness me this is not
in my database i need to find out what i
need to do and uh jeffrey has just shown
us
this is how you play with the white
pieces if your opponent reacts with such
an aggressive opening choice
yeah i think another lesson don't play
this opening is black
yeah you warned already when we saw it
right yeah i mean it
i just knew it had a bad reputation i
didn't know why actually specifically
we've learned why today why white has
such an easy game the queens came off
early that doesn't suit level on ironing
style uh he doesn't want to be playing
an end game and
okay there we go white has parted with
the bishop but won a rook in return and
the black king still finds no solace
he's going to continue getting checked
right now another check the black king
is marching
and uh this game it might well just end
in checkmate
i think we're about to see a result
yeah okay live on iranian he hasn't
resigned yet he's still running with his
king he's dancing around trying to find
safety but what a finish now from
jeffrey zhang uh rook takes pawn and
please show us the checkmate live on
erodian i don't think he's going to show
it i'm going to do it he's going to
resign he resigns instead but what a win
by geoffrey john what a win by jeffrey
chong livon aronian